[Música]
muy buenos días Pues ya aquí en París
estoy en la plaza de Italia es desde
aquí de donde va a dar inicio a esta
manifestación que bien va a atravesar de
oeste a este de este a oeste la capital
todavía está llegando la gente apenas
están llegando pero ya vemos bastante
animación bastantes personas con todo
tipo de de pancartas de mensajes en
contra de esta reforma pensional muchos
mensajes sobre la penosidad del trabajo
uno de los puntos que al parecer esta
reforma no tendría verdaderamente en
cuenta y también las mujeres Ese ha sido
uno de los últimos puntos de los que más
se ha hablado en estos últimos días
porque ellas Pues que muchas de ellas
tienen hay carreras un poco pausadas
cuando deciden ser madres pues ellas
también se verían digamos realizadas por
esta reforma hablamos con algunos de los
participantes aquí de uno de los
sindicatos de profesores una rama que
hoy está en paro en todo el país un poco
más
por ciento de profesores que no
trabajaron el día de hoy que están en
huelga y decían que ellos están por la
concertación quieren que haya un diálogo
Pero ven que por parte del gobierno Pues
hay una posición afirme una posición
donde no quieren exceder lo dijo
la primera ministra este pasado fin de
semana que no darían Un paso atrás en
cuanto a esta reforma que la pensión
pues para pensionarse habrá que hacerlo
a partir de los 64 años y no de los 62
como es actualmente también hace unos
días dijo que respaldaba a su gobierno
respaldaba su primera ministra una
reforma más que necesaria Así que aquí
hay algunas personas que quieren
precisamente esta concertación pero
encuentran que no hay un interlocutor
que esté abierto precisamente al diálogo
Y eso va a llevar a que haya una
radicalización aún más de este
movimiento y que de alguna manera pues
haya mucha más violencia para algunos lo
que se necesita es simplemente que las
empresas comiencen a tener miedo de este
movimiento que se tome digamos a todo el
país y quizás eso que podría ser que el
gobierno quiera sentarse a negociar
abiertamente